ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND SENATE
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
APRIL GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GONZALEZ
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN- SUSHI
THIS AREA AND- WHEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. A. R. TO SMITH. STONE JEAN
MELENDEZ VIA FOOD WELL VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YES YOUR CON YOU MONIES HERE.
AND THE NAME OF OUR- THE MOST
GRACIOUS. THE MOST MERCIFUL.
I'M NOT A GUN. YOUR CREATION IS
CHARACTERIZED BY UNIQUENESS
WHICH WE OFTEN OVERLOOK. EACH
INDIVIDUAL'S TALENTS OUR UNIQUE
AND HIS OR HER CONTRIBUTION TO
SOCIETY OFTEN INDISPENSABLE. WE
SOMETIMES FAIL TO SEE. OPEN OUR
EYES TO THE GOODNESS IN OTHERS.
NEVER LET US IN OUR OWN DESIRE
TO EXCEL. STIFEL IN THE
INITIATIVE OF OTHERS OR CLOSE
DOORS ON THEIR SPECIAL
CONTRIBUTION TO A BETTER WORLD
AND HAPPIER PEOPLE. LET US BE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT GETS
DONE. RATHER THAN WHO DOES IT.
I MEAN. THANK YOU WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PERKS SILVA AS
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR FLAG. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
YOU AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
LIVING THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO MONDAY
JANUARY ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE ASSEMBLY MATTER ONE PM
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE EDS IN THE
PRESIDING CHIEF PARKS ACROSS
THE DESK. SIR SECOND AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
NEEDING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR TODAY'S
ABSENCES FOR ILLNESS THE FAMILY
FAMILY MEMBERS CHEN AND WALDRON
AND FOR MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WORK AND FRAZIER.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE TO
HAVE A GUEST ON THE FLOOR
SEATED AT HER DESK WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. COOPER
GABRIEL NECESSARY- JONES SAWYER
DOLLY AND HOLD THEM. TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS
EIGHT QUICK ENHANCEMENTS. TWO
DAYS ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA'S BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WISHING HIM A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. FILE ITEM ONE
HR TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWELVE BY SOME
MEMBERS JONES AWAY RELATIVE TO
BLACK LIVES MATTER SCHOOL WEEK
OF ACTION. MISTER JONES ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO YOU H. R. TWELVE. A
RESOLUTION TO RECOGNIZE THE
FIRST WEEK OF FEBRUARY AS BLACK
LIVES MATTER AT SCHOOL WEEK OF
ACTION. THIS RESOLUTION IS
TIMELY AS FEBRUARY IS OF COURSE
BLACK HISTORY MONTH. THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER AT SCHOOL WEEK OF
ACTION FIRST BEGAN IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS THE DATA RESILIENCE
FOR SEATTLE'S JOHN MUIR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
WHEN A COMMERCIAL COMMUNITY
LEARN THE TEACHERS WERE
PLANNING TO WEAR SHIRTS SAYING
BLACK LIVES MATTER WE STAND
TOGETHER THEY RECEIVED HATE
THROUGH VERBAL HARASSMENT AND
EVEN A BOMB THREAT. IN SPITE OF
THE INTIMIDATION TEACHERS
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ALL JOINED TOGETHER PROBABLY
WORE THE SHIRTS WHILE IN EVENT
KNOWN AS BLACK MEN UNITED TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE GREETED
AND PRAISED THE YOUTH WITH
ANCESTRAL DRUMS WHILE WEARING
AFROCENTRIC CLOTHING. THE
RESILIENCE OF THE JOHN MUIR
ELEMENTARY COMMUNITY SPARKED A
NATIONAL MOVEMENT ACROSS THE
REST OF SEATTLE. WASHINGTON DC
PHILADELPHIA CHICAGO DETROIT
BOSTON NEW YORK AND OF COURSE
LOS ANGELES. THE DAY OF ACTION
DEVELOPMENT INTO A WEEK OF
CELEBRATING BLACK YOUTH. AND
TEACHING OF THE MANY
ACHIEVEMENTS AND RICH CULTURE
BLACK INDIVIDUALS HAVE MADE
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AND TO THE
COMMUNITY. TO KICK OFF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH RECOGNIZING THE
FIRST WEEK OF FEBRUARY AT THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER AT SCHOOL
WEEK OF ACTION WILL FURTHER UP
LIFT OUR BLACK YOUTH DURING A
TIME. HIGHLIGHTING PRIDE IN OUR
IDENTITY CULTURE AND HISTORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE FIRST ROLE
FOR COOPER'S. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR CO AUTHOR. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS I NEED HER TWELVE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO VERIFY THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. WHERE TWELVE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE THERE
ARE FORTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ON
NATURE TWELVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE
AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WILL REDUCE MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. FILE ITEMS
FOUR THROUGH EIGHT THERE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CALENDAR
CAN THANK OUTER SO BEFORE WE
TAKE A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE ONE ROLL
CALL VOTE TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER
TAUGHT AT ADD ON IS CO AUTHOR
TO THE RESOLUTION THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY
SUMMER FLOOR RELATIVE TO
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WE-
SENDING CURRENT RESOLUTION
FOURTEEN BY SOME UNIVERSAL
RELATIVE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTING AND CAPTIONING WE-
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIVE US IN THE
RIVER CHAU RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA DATA PRIVACY. DAY
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY RELATIVE
TO SCHOOL CHOICE WEEK AND HOUSE
RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY SIN
REMEMBER OUR QUE HAN. RELATIVE
TO MATERNAL HEALTH AWARENESS
DAY. THE CLERK WILL NOW THE
ROLE TO ANY MEMBERS HAD ON IN
THE WATER THESE RESOLUTION. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. LONG MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS WE WISH TO ADD YOUR
NAME AS A CO AUTHOR ON THE
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE VOTE NOW.
CLERIC WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT THERE ARE FIFTY NINE
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL FIVE
NEVER TO REST TO ALL
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. NOW MOVES TO A VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH NINE IS ANY
MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONTENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY SIN
REMEMBER FLOOR RELATIVE TO
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
WEEK. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS. HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHERE TO VOTE. WHERE TWELVE
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
BURGLARY THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
I FIFTIES YOU KNOW ZERO HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIVE I SIXTIES YOU
KNOW ZERO HOUSE MUSICIAN NINE
ICE SIX UNITS ZERO POUNDS WAS
LOSING ELEVEN FIVE SIXTY. ZERO
ENSIGN THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
SIX FIVE SIXTY ZERO
ZERO. MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE TO PHYSICALLY
DISTANCE ON THE FLOOR. MEMBERS
WE HAVE PROTOCOLS ON THIS FLOOR
THAT WE NEED TO MAINTAIN A SIX
FOOT DISTANCE I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE MAINTAIN THAT DISTANCE
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
MISTER COOPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY ABOUT TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY MOM HELLO MARIE
COOPER. MY MOM WAS BORN ON
MARCH SIXTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN IN NEW MADRID MISSOURI TO
MY GRANDPARENTS HAS A BLESSED
BE AND JOHN. LET'S BE. HELLO
GROUP CHICAGO ILLINOIS'
ANYTHING LOUIS MISSOURI SHE WAS
NOT GOING ON LADY WHO ENJOYED
SCHOOL SCHMIT MY LATE FATHER
THURMOND JAMES COOPER AN
AIRFORCE FIREFIGHTER IN HIGH
SCHOOL. THE FILM LOVE WERE
MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
FROM THE UNION MY SISTER SHARON
JERILYN MY BROTHER KEVIN AND I
WERE BORN. MY MOTHER JOINED THE
MILITARY LIKE VERY MUCH IN THE
FAMILY TRAVEL THROUGHOUT EUROPE
THE UNITED STATES. MOST NOTABLY
THEIR STATION FOR DON FRANCE
ROB WAS BORN. AND LATER SIGN MR
FOR SPACE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE MY FAMILY SETTLED IN
RANCHO CORDOVA MY MOM IS A
SCRIBE IS WISE BEYOND HER YEARS
SHE'S AN AMAZING MOTHER
HOMEMAKER AN INTERIOR DECORATOR
SHE'S ALSO THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN HOSTESS IF YOU'LL PULL
THESE RESTAURANT DOWN THE
STREET MY MOTHER HELEN THEN
BEGIN A CAREER WORKING HERE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL RECEIVE WE'RE
TEMPORAL AFTER RETIRING AND
THEN MY MOM BECAME A FOSTER
MOTHER INTO YOUR COMPANION FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. REFERRED TO
AS MOBILE PARK IT MY MOM LOVED
BEING A GRANDMA I COULD NOT ASK
FOR A MORE SUPPORTIVE AND
LOVING GRANDPARENTS TO MY
CHILDREN IS THE SHE TAUGHTME
TO DREAM BIG SHE ALSO TAUGHT MY
KIDS. NIECES AND NEPHEWS THE
SAME. HELLO COOPER WAS AN
AMAZING WOMAN. ALLAMA SURVIVED
BY HER SISTER CHARLENE DYSON
HER CHILDREN. BOB TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN MANY NIECES
NEPHEWS AND FAMILY MEMBERS.
REST IN PEACE MAMA I DON'T
THINK MY COLLEAGUES ARE DOING
THIS THROUGH THIS HARD TIME YOU
GUYS HAVE BEEN FANTASTIC AT THE
FAMILY LAW TEXTS PHONE OF
FLOWERS IN THE EMAILS AND- IT'S
LESS YOU'RE HERE THIS PLACE IS
VERY COLLEGIAL BUT- WE MAY NOT
AGREE SOMETIMES ALL POLITICS
BUT STILL IT'S A FAMILY SO I
THINK EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR KIND WORDS
AND THOUGHTS. IN MY FAMILY
APPRECIATES IT IN ORDER ON IT.
SHE'S EIGHTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
AND SHE HAD SHE HAD HER HEART
WAS FAILING HER. AND HER
KIDNEYS AND HER LIVER. BUT IT
WASN'T COVERED SO SHE'D BEEN IN
OUT OF THE- HOSPITAL AND
SKILLED NURSING FIELD
FACILITIES. FOR THE LAST FOUR
MONTHS I ONLY SAW HER FOUR
TIMES. BECAUSE A COVERT SO.
EVEN THOUGH CHEN DIE FROM
COVERED CALL WOULD HAVE A BIG
RESULT IN OUR FAMILY SO IT'S
VERY TOUGH. SEOUL LIGHTS ONE
THING MY COLLEAGUES AND FOR ALL
YOU DO AND- MY MOM WAS A VERY
VERY STRONG WOMAN LOOKED A LOT
LOST HER PARENTS AT THE AGE OF
FIVE AND SEVEN. SO I WORKED A
LOT OF STRONG WOMEN HERE VERY
STRONG WOMEN. AND THAT'S WHY I
AM WHERE. I AM TODAY BECAUSE
THE FOR. NATURAL WATER YOU FEEL
THE SAME WAY BUT- DEFINITELY.
SELL MOM TAKE VERY MUCH I LOVE
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR ALL OF US WHEN
I SAY OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
ARE WITH YOU AND YOUR ENTIRE
FAMILY. MAY HER MEMORY BE A
BLESSING. MISTER JONES ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF HENRY HAMMERING HANK
AARON A TRAILBLAZING MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL ICON. BORN ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH NINETEEN THIRTY
FOUR THANK WITH THIRTEEN WHEN
HE SAW JACKIE ROBINSON BROKE
THE MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL COLOR
BARRIER. ATTY A YEAR LATER
JACKIE VISITED HANKS HOME TOWN
OF SEGREGATED MOBILE ALABAMA TO
DISCUSS HOW TO OVERCOME
SEGREGATION MOBILE WAS SO
SEGREGATED AT THE TIME THAT
HECK RECALL BEING TOLD MANY
TIMES TO HIDE UNDER THE BED
WHILE THE KKK MARCHED. AND BURN
CROSSES ON BLACK MOUNTAIN TOWN.
JACKIE ROBINSON SPEECH NOT ONLY
IGNITED HANK'S PASSION TO
BECOME A BASEBALL PLAYER IT
ALSO SPARKED HIS. BLAME FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN THANK JOINED THE
INDIANAPOLIS CLOWNS OF THE
NEGRO LEAGUES BASEBALL LEAGUE
FOR AFRIN AMERICANS AS A RESULT
OF RACIST JIM CROW LAWS. IN ITS
FIRST YEAR HEAD HELP WHEN HIS
TEAM THE NINETEEN FIFTY TO
NEGRO LEAGUE WORLD SERIES
TITLE. AFTER SUCCESSFUL YEAR
HIS CONTRACT WAS PURCHASED BY
THE MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL TEAM
THE MILWAUKEE BRAVES ANY WHICH
INTEGRATE THERE MIGHT MINOR
LEAGUE AFFILIATE IN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE. WHEN PLAYING IN
OTHER TEAMS BALLPARKS HANK AT
OTHER NONWHITE TEAMMATES WERE
FORCED TO CHANGE INTO UNIFORMS
SOMEONE SOMEWHERE OTHER THAN
INSIDE THE CHANGING ROOMS.
WHICH WERE RESERVED FOR HIS
WHITE TEAMMATES HOLDING ON TO
JACKIE ROBINSON'S PIVOTAL
SPEECH HAD NEVER FALTERED IN
HIS DETERMINATION TO SHATTER
THE GLASS CEILING FOR OTHER
YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN PLAYERS
TO COME. IN HIS FIRST YEAR
ALONE HANK HIT THIRTEEN HOME
RUNS BEING HIT TWENTY SEVEN
MORE HOME RUNS AND A HUNDRED
AND SIX RBIS THAT'S RUNS BATTED
IN FOR YOU NON BASEBALL FOLKS.
ARE IN HIS NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
SEASON HE NOT ONLY WON HIS
FIRST BATTING TITLE IN NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN BUT ALSO EARNED THE
TITLE. OF NATIONAL LEAGUE MVP
AFTER HE FORTY ADDITIONAL RUNS
DURING THE- INNING OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WORLD
SERIES GAME HEAD HIT THE TITLE
WINNING HOME RUN. POSITIONING
THE UNDERDOG BRAVES AT THE
WORLD SERIES CHAMPIONS OVER THE
NEW YORK YANKEES AND THEIR
SEVEN GAME SERIES ALWAYS CAREER
HAD HIT AT LEAST FORTY HOME
RUNS IN SEVERAL SEASON. BEST
EARNING HIM THE NICKNAME
HAMMERING HANK. AS HE
APPROACHED BABE RUTH'S RECORD
OF SEVEN HUNDRED FOURTEEN
CAREER HOME RUNS. THANK YOU CAN
RECEIVE IN A EVEN GREATER
INFLOW OF HATRED AND EVEN DEATH
THREATS. THE KNOWLEDGE AIMED AT
THOSE WHO ACTED WITH SUCH
RACISM RESENTED THE FACT THAT
HE WAS GOING TO BREAK A WHITE
MAN'S RECORD. THANK WOULD
RESPOND THAT HE DID NOT WANT
PEOPLE TO FORGET BABE RUTH. HE
JUST WANTED THEM TO REMEMBER
HANK AIR. FOUR DAYS FOLLOWING
HIS FIRST AT BAT OF THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR SEASON
HAMMERING HANK HIT HIS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN HOME RUN.
BECOMING A NEW HOME RUN RECORD
HOLDER. THANK FINISHES CAREER.
IF HIS TWENTY THIRD. YEAR
CAREER WITH A TOTAL OF SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE HOME RUNS. A
RECORD HELD FOR THIRTY THREE
YEARS. TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN RBI. SIX THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
TOTAL BASIS ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN AFTER
BASIS. TWELVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR AT BACK
APPEARANCES AND AN AMAZING.
TWENTY FIVE. ALL STAR
APPEARANCES IN TWENTY ONE
SEASONS AS AN ALL STAR BOTH.
RECORDS TO THIS DAY. AWARDS AND
TITLES EARNED OVER HIS CAREER
INCLUDED NATIONAL LEAGUE IS
BATTLING BATTING TITLE IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. NATIONAL LEAGUE
MVP AWARD IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN AND THREE GOLDEN GLOBE
AWARDS FROM NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT TO NINETEEN SIXTY.
FOLLOWING HIS RETIREMENT
PAPERWORK AT THE ATLANTA BRAVES
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT. WHERE
HE SERVED AS THE LEADING
SPOKESPERSON CHAMPION MINORITY
HIRING IN ITALY. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK ERA WAS
INDUCTED INTO THE NATIONAL
BASEBALL HALL OF FAME.
PERMANENTLY ENSHRINING HIS
RECORD BREAKING BASEBALL
CAREER. IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
HECK RECEIVED THE PRESIDENTIAL
CITIZENS MEDAL FROM PRESIDENT
CLINTON. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO HE RECEIVED THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM
FROM PRESIDENT BUSH. THANK IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE BILLY.
AARON AND HIS SIX CHILDREN.
LET'S ALL REMEMBER THIS QUOTE
FROM HANK AARON. IT IS A GREAT
THING TO BE THE MAN WHO HIT THE
MOST HOME RUNS. BUT IS A
GREATER THING TO BEAT A MAN WHO
DID THE MOST WITH THE HOME RUNS
HE HIT. SO LONG AS THERE'S A
CHANCE THAT MAYBE I CAN HAMMER
OUT A LITTLE JUSTICE NOW AND
THEN. I INTEND TO DO AS I
ALWAYS. HAVE KEEP SWINGING. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT. AS WE
LOOK AT ALL THE THINGS THAT
HAPPEN IN BASEBALL ALL THE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN. A LOT OF
THE SPORTS. I DON'T THINK IF
YOU GOOGLE HANK AARON'S NAME.
IT WOULD BE ANY SCANDAL. WOULD
BE ANY CONTROVERSY. HE HE WAS
THE MAN THAT WAS SO ECSTATIC.
THAT HE RETIRED FROM BASEBALL
YEAH HOME RUN THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT HIM.
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF HENRY HAMMERING HANK AARON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHNSON WHERE IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
NOW LIFTED BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
OUR ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY I'D ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. I RISE TODAY TO
REQUEST OF ME JOURN IN MEMORY
OF MARLENE BEING A BELOVED
COMMUNITY LEADER IN THE WEST
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MARLENE WAS A TRUE
FORCE OF NATURE WHO BUILT A
LASTING LEGACY THROUGH HER
DECADES OF TIRELESS ADVOCACY
LEADERSHIP AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
MARLENE HAD DEEP CONNECTIONS TO
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. PART OF A
DYNAMIC DUO WITH HER LATE
HUSBAND FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TOM BAIN FOR WHOM OUR RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM IS NAMED SHE WAS
A POWERFUL PRESENCE IN THESE
HALLS FOR MANY DECADES. AMONG
HER ROLE SHE SERVED AS A CHIEF
CONSULTANT AND IS A KEY
FUNDRAISER FOR SPEAKER WILLIE
BROWN WHO OFTEN CALLED HER THE
BEST IN THE BUSINESS. MARLENE
WAS ALSO AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE URBAN LEAGUE THE END DOUBLE
ACP AND THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS. ALWAYS GENEROUS WITH
HER TIME AND ADVICE.
GENERATIONS OF ACTIVISTS AND
POLITICAL LEADERS BENEFITTED
FROM MARLENE'S WISE GUIDANCE
AND COMMITMENT TO MENTORSHIP.
ON A PERSONAL LEVEL I STILL
RECALL THE IMMENSE PRIDE THAT I
FELT UPON HER NEED HER SUPPORT.
DURING MY FIRST RUN FOR OFFICE.
AND HOW MUCH I APPRECIATED HER
GOOD ADVICE AND GENUINE
KINDNESS OVER THE YEARS. INDEED
UP THROUGH THE LAST WEEK OF HER
LIFE MARLENE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ADVICE AND GUIDANCE AND
SUPPORT TO CANDIDATES THAT SHE
BELIEVED IN. ALSO CENTRAL TO
MARLENE'S LIFE AND WORK WITH
HER COMMITMENT TO ADVOCATING
FOR THE JEWISH COMMUNITY AND
THE STATE OF ISRAEL. SHE WAS A
LONGTIME LEADER WITH THE
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE AND IT WAS WITH GREAT
PRIDE LAST YEAR THAT AGENCY
ESTABLISHED THE MARLENE BAIN
DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC SERVICE
AWARD. IN HER HONOR. FITTINGLY
THE INAUGURAL AWARD WAS
PRESENTED TO ANOTHER DYNAMIC
LEADER FORMER UC PRESIDENT
JANET UPPALA TANO. YANTAR MANY
PROFESSIONAL ACCOMPLISHMENTS
MARLENE WAS A BELOVED WIFE
MOTHER GRANDMOTHER GREAT
GRANDMOTHER AND FRIEND. SHE
WILL BE REMEMBERED ABOVE ALL
FOR HER KINDNESS HER GENEROSITY
AND HER DEEP COMMITMENT TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MAY HER MEMORY BE A
BLESSING AND MAY WE ARE JOINED
TODAY IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL MISTER IS THERE AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE ELOQUENT WORDS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE WEST VALLEY
WHO SPOKE LOVINGLY ABOUT
MARLENE WHO. WAS A MENTOR AND A
FRIEND TO ALL OF US- I FIRST
MET MARLENE HAD THE WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY OF MEETING HER.
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG SAFFER
WORKING IN MY FIRST JOB FOR A
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS. AND THE DAY AFTER SHE
SENT ME A HAND WRITTEN NOTE
WHICH GOT ME TO A PLACE WHERE
SOME OF YOU HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
HAND WRITTEN NOTES FROM ME. ON
A VERY REGULAR BASIS- MARLENE
HAD THIS INFECTIOUS WAY OF
GETTING YOU ENGAGED. AND
SOMEONE WHO UNDERSTOOD THE
VALUE OF KEEPING RELATIONSHIPS
REGARDLESS OF WHO YOU WERE
WHETHER YOU WERE A YOUNG LOWLY
STAFFER. OR A HIGH LEVEL
ELECTED OFFICIAL WHO HAD BEEN
IN OFFICE FOR DECADES. SHE HAD
A WAY ABOUT HER OF ENGAGING AND
ENSURING THAT YOU GET INVOLVED
AS WELL- I JUST WANT TO RECOUNT
ONE A QUICK EXPERIENCE. I
UNFORTUNATELY SAW HER LAST A
YEAR AGO HAPPENED TO SEE HER
ADDED DAILY I WAS HAVING LUNCH
AT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND- HER
SON NEIL CAME TO ME AFTERWARDS
I GOT WHEN I AFTER WE EXCHANGED
PLEASANTRIES AND HUGGED EACH
OTHER- NEIL CAME TO ME AND SAID
MAKE SURE YET THAT YOU TALK TO
HER BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW. HOW
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE GOING-
SO I QUICKLY CALLED HER
AFTERWARDS TO CHECK IN. AND OF
COURSE AS HE PICKED UP THE
PHONE. SHE SAID DARLING I DID
SEND YOU A CHECK THEIR NINE. I
SAID MARLENE OF COURSE YOU TO
EAT THAT THAT WASN'T THE REASON
I JUST WANTED TO. CHECK IN AND
SEE HOW YOU ARE BUT- THAT WAS
THE PERSON THAT SHE WAS. EVEN
IN THE DARKEST TIME IN THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIME OF HER LIFE.
SHE NEVER STOPPED THINKING AND
FUNCTIONING. AND CONTINUING
THAT SHARP WITTED WAY OF. GOING
ABOUT HER BUSINESS I WILL
SORELY MISS HER. HER ADVICE OR
MENTORSHIP- AND THE LOVE SHE
HAD FOR THIS INSTITUTION AND
THE LOVE SHE HAD FOR HER LATE
HUSBAND TOM BEING- MAY HER
MEMORY BE A BLESSING TO ALL OF
US THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN MR COOLEY RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER. COLLEAGUES
I'M HONORED TO STAND HERE IN
HONOR OF MARLENE. LINE GOT TO
KNOW IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES-
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE MEETS
OR WHAT IS THE COMBINATION
RIGHT OF THE HOLE HERE YOU'LL
SEE TOM'S SIGN ON THAT DOOR-
TOM BRADY'S OFFICE WITH JUST.
TWO OFFICES AWAY FROM GROUP
HAPPENS OFFICE MARLENE BRAIN
AND LOOP HAPPENS WIFI REINBOLD
HAD LUPUS. AND I PROVIDED A
SPECIAL CONNECTION OF LOOP
HAPPEN WOULD LEAVE HIS WIFE AT
HOME AND TRAVEL UP HERE AND DO
HIS WORK MARLENE WAS OFTEN HERE
WITH TOM. AND SHE WOULD POP IN
AND JUST OFFER CAMARADERIE AND
SUPPORT TO LOU PAPPAS AS HIS
WIFE IRENE WAS DEALING WITH
STRUGGLE WITH LUPUS.
PREDECEASED MISTER POPPIN- BUT
YEAH MARLEY WERE JUST A VERY
EXCEPTIONAL PERSON YOU WOODS
OFFICE HERE IN THE HALLWAYS
WITH COM SHE WAS JUST VERY
ENGAGING AND JUST HAD A TENDER
HEART AND AS I SAY YOU KNOW
LOOP HAPPEN HAD THE NICKNAME BY
A FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF OF
GOVERNOR BROWN. OF DOG- THE IN.
HE WAS OFTEN SEEN AS SORT OF
THIS FIERCE PERSON. MARLEEN
JUST TREAT HIM AS SUCH
TENDERNESS ON THIS AREA IT WAS
SO VITAL TO HIM. OF HIS ALIEN
LIFE AND- SO I WAS JUST A VERY
VERY EXCEPTIONAL WOMAN. AND A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
PROCESS. AND WAS. RESOUND
THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING- ANYWAY
SO I'M HONORED TO JOIN THE AND
REFLECTED UPON HER LIFE. RIMPAC
HERE AND ONE EXCEPTIONAL LIFE
LIVE. THANK YOU MR COOLEY.
MITHALI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
ENTER IN THE MEMORY OF
RESPECTED STATESMAN VETERAN AND
MENTOR TO MANY. THREE FAR A
MEMBER OF THE SHASTA LAKE CITY
COUNCIL RECENTLY PASSED AWAY AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY FOUR. FOR
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS HE SPENT
SERVING THE COMMUNITY OF SHASTA
LAKE WE HONOR HIS MEMORY AND
HIS PUBLIC SERVICE TODAY. FARR
SERVED AS THE FIRST MAYOR OF
SHASTA LAKE- TO THIS FAR WITH
THE WATER RESOURCES ENGINEER
THAT SERVED FOR TEN YEARS ON
THE BOARD FOR THE SHASTA DAM
AREA PUBLIC UTILITY DISTRICT.
DURING HIS TENURE FAR WAS AT
THE FOREFRONT OF SEVERAL MAJOR
PROJECTS THAT ADVANCES
COMMUNITY FAR. THE US AIRFORCE
VETERAN ALWAYS ATTENDED THE
CITY'S ANNUAL VETERANS PARADE.
COMPLETED DYNAMIC ROLE IN THIS
COMMUNITY BOTH PROFESSIONALLY
AND PERSONALLY. HIS LEADERSHIP
AND COMMITMENT TO SHASTA LAKE
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS FRIENDS AND
FAMILY WHO WILL CHERISH HIS
MEMORY. WHAT IS DEDICATION AND
DRIVE TO SERVE BE AN
INSPIRATION TO US ALL MEMBERS I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN HONORING
THE MEMORY OF LARRY FAR. THANK
YOU MISTER ALI. MR HOLDEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORIES. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER BETTY STAFFORD WAS A
BELOVED AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
MONROVIA COMMUNITY SHE GREW UP
IN MONROVIA WHERE HER FATHER
AND MOTHER RAN A SHOE STORE.
SHE MET HER BELOVED HUSBAND
JEWELS WHILE IN COLLEGE. THEY
MARRIED SOON AFTER AND MOVED
BACK TO MONROVIA WHERE THEY
BUILT A LIFE TOGETHER. WHEN
THEY WERE WORK WHEN THEY
WEREN'T WORKING THEY LOVE TO
TRAVEL THROUGHOUT THE US AND
OVERSEAS. AFTER THE PASSING OF
HER HUSBAND BETTY CONTINUE TO
TRAVEL TO UNITS UP PROJECT
SITES AND PARTICIPATE ANOTHER
HUMANITARIAN ACTIVITIES. FOR
ACTIVISM STARTED SOON AFTER
GIVING BIRTH TO HER FIRST CHILD
A TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF AGE. AS
THE FOREIGN POLICY CHAIR OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS IN
MONROVIA. THAT EVENTUALLY LED
TO HER LET HER TO BECOME
UNICEF'S VOLUNTEER DIRECTOR FOR
SEVEN STATES. THROUGHOUT HER
LIFE SHE WAS A PART OF MANY
LOCAL AND NATIONAL EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE SCHOOLS. CREATE HE
CITY'S FIRST HEAD START
PROGRAM. ADVOCATING FOR SCHOOL
INTEGRATION AND FOR NUCLEAR
FREEZE ADVOCACY. SHE HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO MANY OTHER
NONPROFITS IN OUR LONG LIFETIME
AND RECEIVED MANY AWARDS FOR
HER WORK. BUT AS HER BIOGRAPHY
SAYS IT IS UP TO OTHERS TO GIVE
THE FULL STORY OF WHAT SHE HAS
DONE. BECAUSE OF THE ONE SAID
WHAT HASN'T HE DONE. WE HAVE TO
TELL THE STORY BECAUSE OF HER
BECAUSE FOR HER. IT WAS JUST
ABOUT DOING THE WORK THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE. THIS IS
CAPTURED IN HER FINAL ADVICE TO
US ALL. DON'T JUST TALK ABOUT
IT DO IT. THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF
MEDICINE. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAME
FOR THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. WE
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
FEBRUARY FIFTH NO FLOOR SESSION
AND NO CHECK IN SESSION. MONDAY
FEBRUARY EIGHTH WITH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HEARING OVER
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS RASMUSSEN RESTAURANT TO
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY FEBRUARY
AT ONE PM.